ladies and gentlemen hello happy to
see that some of you are
still in the press room today
[Music]
despite the situation thank you for that
I also greet all the colleagues who
are watching us live at ubs
we are in a new phase of the
media briefing a phase in which
we are going to test in a way a
double line of work on the one hand to
allow those of you who
came to the press room to ask your
questions as usual and on the other
hand to those who  are watching by
ubs and who are accredited journalists
in brussels i insist on this
point to ask us questions by
email today and in an
interactive way i have here an ipad on
which the questions which are asked are
then displayed to all  those who are
watching and have failed to
email us i am
aware that the email address it seems to be
working for some colleagues and not
for others
we are drooling  er stieg and
what can be the reasons and and
to remedy it I believe that today
is a day a little bit of testing
and we will of course try
to improve things
as the days go by  the coming days
and to adapt the the procedures
that we were the procedures that we
use to allow you to date
react with everything but I see that I
already have three questions which shows that
some of you have access I
also thank you for respecting a certain
distance between you to
respect the hygiene instructions which at
the moment are absolutely
essential and we will try
to ensure that you can
work in the
safest possible conditions
darling darling being used in baghdad  in
zhuhai sir koala bezy weekend
[Music]
video that presides over a posture went there
all told us that they name
active life and izri continues we have quite and
bezy in jeddah needs  s of the various
so we have the following who meeting this
video conference organized six ministers
and men and 48 roughly a
commissionaire that there is kid s
hewson the native of major forbach
you protect me and i want a type
essentials goods flowing alive internal
market with respect to the media cd and wilshere
29 16 a pitch enix continue to receive
the times
mariko equipment
ensisheim time to another
good besides believes him years for economy
you continue to operate
15 what he has a chance mailman druid
to be hot all the
civil servants have saved flying
sodisca this empty coming procurement in 28
years at the restaurant medical device singh
and the president announces isdn you can
find more information we say to the daily
news
then at 3 p.m. the president will
participate in the videoconference with
the  leaders of the g 7 discussions which of
course will aim to
discuss the situation related to
the chrono virus crisis and the president in this
context deb  riefera will inform the
leaders about the actions
taken by the commission in this
context at 5.30 a.m. the president will have a
videoconference with the management of
the company curé vac which is a
company which develops
technologies for in the field of
vaccines
a company which is coming  of
human tulle in germany and they will discuss
together the best ways to
ensure that we can support
the activities of this company in
europe note in fate exact date vice
president so thanks to a
gasoil jacket that michel gentiloni where
they represent  commissions he regretted
in total 13 via videoconference readers
all mythical names stock of thee i
chronicle situation of ska
french cities all aim short challenger
until 10 offers to communicate your
opinion
the iphone app of the stand are you going to live
president of pink and  so charles michel
in saint just not that there will be and
video like french with the pink an  d so
leader tomorrow is wight of ska
development action
they were all to enter you
will also find in our daily news
more information on the measures
announced yesterday to ensure the
availability of supplies
of personal protective equipment
by requiring that it  is the exports
of its teams of its equipment
forgiveness outside the European Union either
subject to export authorizations
by the member states or an infinite time
week by week this makes a good
like to as usual crisis
its tail with 1